when I haven't tasted blood in a while I  don't really I don't notice I'm not  sitting there thinking about it and then  all of a sudden something will happen  some situation will unfold and I'll I'll  go into were like war mode and I I just  feel so good it makes me just look  around and I just think you know it  wasn't really supposed to be doing  anything else because it makes me feel  so good to dip to be in that mode to  feel that focus when I have somebody or  some entity that is antagonistic to me  and my family my friends when I feel  something  is the best - whether it was the enemy  whether it is part of some organization  some person that had some dude did  something you know if there's a betrayal  scenario where someone at the trace  and they want to go to war  that's when I'd love to taste the blood  [Music]